hi my name is Alice guy and I'm studio
head here at page 7 welcome to a deeper
dive into the gameplay of our new game
black book crossing out early next year
on pc xbox and ps4 so for those who are
new to the game blackwood crossings are
thought-provoking storage driven
adventure game centered around orphan
siblings Scarlett and Finn you play as
14 year-old Scarlett being led through a
mysterious journey by your 10 year old
brother Finn you're once close bond has
broken down the Scarlets come of age and
just leaving childhood behind come on
you promised what did I promise
don't remember what a promise is a
promise here we're doing the game partly
through the first chapter the game is
largely set on a moving train but we're
starting to get a sense that this is no
ordinary journey and that Finn is
behaving in some pretty unexpected ways
Finn where did you go
leaves following him down the train here
we start to reveal some of the magic and
the mystery to the player finna seen
magically dissolving into leaves and
then as we follow him into the train
carriage you see it transforming into a
garden landscape of their eyes different
wait Finn don't go up there Finn we
don't know it safe Finn I need you to
put the ladder back and climb down you
can't come up without the password I
don't like this Finn I'm not playing
anymore no no Scarlet doesn't know the
password at this point in the game set a
password pozna that we must solve so we
can follow fina balada hidden around the
carriage of several Polaroids that will
give us the clues we need to solve the
puzzle
dad's old guitar he could really play
what's this I remember this it's a
made-up language we used to use
another one princess Scarlett to the
rescue the shadowed images play out a
story where princess Scarlett has
rescued Finn from the dragon the words
we see or a secret language they used
when they were younger and as we walk
down here we see the train is
transformed again this ties into a grand
a greenhouse finn there's no one driving
the Train come on I'm not kidding
there's just granddad's greenhouse you
really should see it I've seen
granddad's greenhouse loads of times
grandparents have been caring for
Scarlett and fins and step of their
parents several years before so they do
feature strongly in their lives it's
also another chance for us to add
intrigue and Wonder to the environment
and give the player of further glimpse
into the backstory granddad used to hide
here for hours listening to the cricket
ace that's what you get when you miss
that's the whole story now what order do
they go in so now we found all the
Polaroids when we can head back to the
tree to solve the puzzle black were
crossing is a storage of the game at its
heart for sure but we feel is a really
nice balance between the narrative
clearance in the puzzle expiration
moment we want there to be enough to
keep the players mind turning and not so
much that it breaks them out of the flow
of the story ever bear
we can now climb the ladder and we're
able to see Scarlett's full body in this
view we've worked hard to craft many
little details like this so for example
here the legs being visible I thought if
you look closely its pilots hands you
can see her nail varnish is chipped it's
all part of making the player understand
just to Scarlett is and what she's about
the treehouse now we've transported the
player to Finn and Scarlets childhood
treehouse and are about to enter a key
scene in the story it's not just a
beautiful environment it also allows us
to play out key scenes in the story this
one is particularly important
finally I almost given up grandma says
come down and start your homework I need
you to help with the drawing I'm off out
with Cam Cameron you don't have to leave
right away though do you a past version
of scarlet is shown interacting with in
here and we do this at several points
during the game of course here we're
showing the player how her move into
adolescence fine super sexy at a time
she spent eight so now we have to find
the two objects that delete it i fin
facilitate done scissors
look at all this stuff
are you ever going to finish that roof
one day generally speaking all the
puzzles in the game serve to further the
players understanding of Finn and
Scarlets relationship and the events
that are unfolding do you remember your
robot phase Russ it wasn't a face ruff
ruff robots are cool
Rosco drop woof good boy
the game is set in the mid 90s so you'll
often see nice retro touches throughout
the game like these where are the
scissors try the planetarium
the thing with the planets yes yes
planets are big round things
you
we should do another dinner time theatre
so if we explore the treehouse we hear
relatable childlike conversations
between the two main characters per
genius when he puts his mind to it what
was that nothing
there they are
the teams worked hard to make sure the
puzzles don't feel too mechanical we
never want to break the player out of
the story in the interactions that
follow will see Finn and Scarlett
questioning each other about the issues
that are uppermost in their mind for
Scarlett that's what's going on and why
they're on this journey for Finn it's
seeking more information about their
dead parents and giving us an insight
into the emotional turmoil he's been
feeling come on let's get started we're
doing butterflies oh okay you draw I'll
do the white Finn do you remember the
train that we were on before
there were some people wearing masks did
you like them that's not what I meant I
can make you one if you like no Finn I
want to know why they're here
fin we're all on a journey we don't seem
to be getting very far do you know where
we're going why would I know anything a
fat lot of help you are
I don't even know who those people are
you know grandma and granddad and cam
and mrs. Lin toast and that boy from
your school you mean mom and dad how's
that nice the interactions of the
butterflies allow us to break up the
conversation very naturally and we'll
see how they use distraction techniques
to avoid the difficult questions as
children so often do you remember them
who mom and dad you can remember don't
it's important
not when I concentrate but I dream about
them and it's like they're right there
then I wake up and they're gone can you
describe them to me I don't know dad was
very tall but I suppose everyone was he
let me sit on his shoulders when I
couldn't see and one here and what about
mom that's enough but you're lucky you
don't remember you wouldn't say that if
you knew what's that supposed to mean
I finished no Finn what did you mean do
you want to wind it up can't you
remember them at all no they loved you
very much I hope so here watch this
that's a good one watch me how did you
do that I don't know I just wanted it to
fly can you do again I don't know you
try it's magic that's amazing sorry Finn
I've really got to go we'll play later
okay oh no they're all rubbish I can't
do them on my own now we're saying what
happened when Scarlett didn't stay with
him and play with him he's not and it
sets up the next chapter which has much
darker elements and many more surprises
for the best you can get to short
glimpse of what's to come in the reveal
trailer that we released a few weeks ago
oh hello good
none of them are any good then get to
hold of yourself hey Finn where did you
get that it's all your fault
stop it
as you have seen the game tackles some
pretty heavy topics love loves for
letting go their key themes that run
throughout we've written a story and
designed a game that's there to make you
think and feel it's a game that will
appeal to those with a sense of
adventure and a vivid imagination who
enjoy a good story and solving puzzles
hopefully you'll have enjoyed this
insight and we look forward to sharing
more with you over the coming weeks as
we build up to our release early next
year cheers for watching